social dilemma is a popular documentary
that raised concerns about the effects
of social media and society
you responded with a point-by-point
rebuttal titled what the social dilemma
gets wrong people should read that
i would say the key point they make is
because social media is funded by ads
algorithms want to maximize attention
and engagement and
an effective way to do so is to get
people angry at each other increase
division and so on
can you steal man their criticisms and
arguments that they make in the
documentary as a way to understand the
concern and
as a way to respond to it
well yeah i think i think that that's a
good conversation to have um i i don't
happen to agree with the the conclusions
and i think that they make a few
assumptions that are
um
just very big jumps that i i don't think
are reasonable to make but i understand
overall
why people would be concerned that
our business model and ads in general
um
we do make more money as people use the
service more in general right so as a
kind of basic assumption okay do we have
an incentive for people to to build a
service that people use more
yes on a lot of levels i mean we think
what we're doing is good so um you know
we think that if people are finding it
useful they'll use it more um or if you
just look at it as this
sort of if the only thing we cared about
is money which i i is is not for anyone
who knows me but okay we're a company so
let's say you just kind of um simplified
it down to that then would we want
people to use the services more
yes
but then and then you get to the second
question which is
does kind of getting people agitated
make them more likely to use
the services more
and
i think from looking at other media in
the world
especially tv and you know there's the
old news
adage if it bleeds it leads like i think
that this is there are
i thought there were a bunch of
reasons why someone might think that
um
that kind of provocative content would
be the most engaging
now what i've always found is is two
things one is that will grab someone's
attention in the near term
is not necessarily something that
they're going to appreciate having seen
or going to be the best over the long
term so i think what a lot of people get
wrong is that we're not i'm not building
this company to like make the most money
or get people to spend the most time on
this in the next quarter or the next
year right i mean i've been doing this
for
you know 17 years at this point and i'm
still relatively young and you have a
lot more that i want to do over the
coming decades so like
i think that it's too simplistic to say
hey
this might increase time in the near
term therefore it's what you're going to
do because i actually think a a deeper
look at it kind of what my incentives
are the incentives of a company that are
focused on the long term
is to
basically do what people are going to
find valuable over time not what is
going to draw people's attention today
the other thing that i'd say is that
i think a lot of times people look at
this from the perspective of media
um
or or kind of information or civic
discourse but one other way of looking
at this is just that okay i'm a product
designer right our company you know we
build products and
a big part of building a product is not
just the function and utility of what
you're delivering but the feeling of how
it feels right we spent a lot of time
talking about um you know virtual
reality and how the the kind of key
aspect of that experience is the the
feeling of presence which it's a
visceral thing it's not just about the
utility that you're delivering it's
about like the sensation
and
similarly
i care a lot about how people feel when
they use our products and
i don't want to build products that make
people angry i mean that's like not i
think what we're here on this earth to
do is to you know build something that
you know people spend a bunch of time
doing and it just kind of makes them
angrier to other people i mean i think
that that's that's not good that's you
know that's that's not what i think
would be um
sort of a good use of of our time or a
good contribution to the world so okay
you know it's like people
they tell us on a per content basis you
know does this thing you know do i like
it do i love it does it make me angry
does it make me sad and you know based
on that i i mean we we choose to
basically show content that makes people
angry less um because you know of course
right if you're if you're designing a
product and you want people to to be
able to um
to to connect and and feel good over
over a long period of time then that's
um you know naturally what you're gonna
do so i don't know i think overall
i um
i understand
at a high level
if you're not thinking
too deeply about it why that argument
might be appealing
but
i just think if you actually look at
what our real incentives are not just
like
you know is
if we were trying to optimize for the
next week um but like as people working
on this like why are we here
and
i i think it's pretty clear that's not
actually how you would want to design
the system i guess one other thing that
i'd say is that you know while we're
focused on the the ads business model
i do think it's important to note that
a lot of these issues are not unique to
ads i mean so take like a subscription
news business model for example
i think that has you know just as many
potential pitfalls um you know maybe if
someone's paying for a subscription you
don't get paid per piece of content that
they look at but
you know say for example i i think like
a bunch of the partisanship that we see
could potentially be made worse
by
you have these these kind of partisan
um
news organizations that basically sell
subscriptions and they're only going to
get people on one side to basically
subscribe to them
so their incentive is not to um print
content or or or produce content that's
kind of centrist or down the line either
i bet that what a lot of them find is
that if they produce stuff that's that's
kind of more polarizing or more partisan
then um then that is what gets them more
subscribers
so
i i think that this stuff is all
um there's no perfect business model
everything has pitfalls um the thing
that i think is great about advertising
is it makes it the consumer services
free which if you if you believe that
everyone should have a voice and
everyone should be able to connect and
that's a great thing
um you know as opposed to building a
luxury service that not everyone can
afford but look i mean every business
model you know you have to be careful
about how you're implementing what
you're doing
you responded to a few things there you
spoke to the fact that you know there is
a narrative of malevolence
like um
you know you're leaning into the making
people angry just because it makes more
money in the short term that kind of
thing so you you responded to that but
there's also kind of
reality of human nature
just like you spoke about there's fights
arguments we get in and we don't like
ourselves afterwards but we got into
them anyway so our long-term growth is
i i believe for most of us has to do
with learning
challenging yourself improving
being kind to each other finding a
community of people that uh
you know you
uh connect with on a real human level
all that kind of stuff
but it does seem when you look at social
media that a lot of fights break out a
lot of arguments break out a lot of
viral content ends up being sort of
outraged in one direction or the other
and so it's easy from that to infer the
narrative that
social media companies are letting this
outrage become viral
and so they're increasing the division
in the world
and perhaps you can comment on that or
further how can you be
how can you
push back on this narrative how can you
be transparent about this battle because
i think it's not just
motivation or
financials
it's a technical problem too which is
how do you improve
long-term well-being of human beings
i think that going through
some of the design decisions
would be a good conversation but first i
actually think you know i think
you acknowledge that you know that
narrative is somewhat anecdotal and i
think it's worth grounding this
conversation in
the actual research that has been done
on this which
by and large
finds that
social media is not a large driver of
polarization right and um you know i
mean there's been a number of um
economists and social scientists and
folks who have studied this
in a lot of polarization it varies
around the world
you know social media is basically in
every country facebook's in pretty much
every country except for china and maybe
north korea
and
um and you see different trends in
different places
where
you know in a lot of countries
polarization is declining
um in some it's flat in the u.s it's
it's risen sharply
so
the question is what are the unique
phenomena in the different places and i
think for the people who are trying to
say hey social media is the thing that's
doing this
i think that that clearly doesn't hold
up because social media is a phenomenon
that is pretty much equivalent in all of
these different countries and you have
researchers like this economist at
stanford matthew ginskow who's just
written um at length about this um
and um
you know it's a bunch of books by you
know political scientists ezra klein and
folks why we're polarized basically goes
through this decades-long analysis in
the us
before i was born basically talking
about some of the forces and kind of
partisan politics and fox news and
different things that predate the
internet in a lot of ways that that i
think are likely larger contributors so
to the contrary on this
not only is is it
pretty clear that social media is not a
major contributor but most of the
academic studies that i've seen actually
show that social media use
is is correlated with lower polarization
um
gensco the same person who just did the
study that i cited about longitudinal
polarization across different countries
you know also
did a study that basically showed that
if you looked after you know the 2016
election in the u.s the voters who are
the most polarized um were actually the
ones who were not on the internet
so and there have been recent other
studies i think in europe um and around
the world basically showing that
as people
stop using social media they tend to get
more polarized um then there's a deeper
analysis around okay well what
polarization actually isn't even one
thing um because you know having
different opinions on something isn't i
don't think that that's by itself bad
what what people who study this say is
um
most problematic is what they call
affective polarization which is
basically are you do you have negative
feelings towards people of another group
and the way that a lot of scholars study
this is they basically
ask a group
would you let your kids marry someone of
group x whatever the the groups are that
you're that you're worried that someone
might have negative feelings towards and
in general use of social media has
corresponded to decreases in that kind
of affective polarization so i i just
want to i think we should talk through
the design decisions and how we handle
um the the kind of specific pieces of
content but
overall i think it's just worth
grounding that discussion in the
research that's existed that i think
overwhelmingly shows that the mainstream
narrative around this is just not right
but the the narrative does take hold
and um
it's compelling to a lot of people
you